dès la mi mars j'ai demandé à ce que des
kits de protection soient distribués
dans toutes les voitures de police et de
gendarmerie des kits de protection avec
notamment du gel et des masques de la
même façon dans tous les lieux d'accueil
du public pour les polices pour les
policiers et pour les gendarmes et j'ai
précisé des masques qui devaient être
portées conformément à la doctrine
déterminé par les scientifiques c'est à
dire en cas d'intervention devant des
personnes présentant des symptômes ou
dans les cas de figure présentant un
risque important
il appartient aux policiers mais c'est
ce qu'ils font à chaque contrôle
d'apprécier la situation et de décider
cela des masques dont nous avons
d'ailleurs fait tout de suite des
commandes quand c'était nécessaire même
dont nous disposions aussi au niveau de
notre équipement de base
les chiffres sur ce sujet évolue en
permanence ils ont d'ailleurs changé
depuis mon audition la semaine dernière
à l'assemblée nationale et voici ce que
je peux avancer à la date du 15 avril 9
millions de masques sont à la
disposition du ministère de l'intérieur
et 4 millions qu'ont déjà été répartis
dans les unités d'ici la fin avril 9
millions de masques supplémentaires
seront livrés et au total ce sont 60
millions de masques que le ministère de
l'intérieur a commandé je n'évoque pas
mais peut-être je préciserai plus tard
tout le matériel complémentaire aussi
lunettes visière et autre matériel que
nous avons acheté aussi pour
expérimenter la meilleure protection
possible pour nos forces de sécurité
intérieure